It was just,
it was fun having a kid style podcasts.
Is it nurse did, were you nervous
at first to have them? Yes. Yeah.
Nervous to be vulnerable,
nervous to love something
that much nervous to have
that kind of responsibility.
Nervous about all those things change
as you change as you like nothing else.
But did you feel like the changes would
be for like a that you won't like the
changes and then you did like, I'm
like, did you have reservations? Well,
I didn't have a relationship
with my father growing up,
so for me it's very,
it was very,
very important that I did whatever I had
to do to have a relationship with them,
to be as present as I can be,
to like whatever,
whoever I was before I had them to,
to evolve to get better.
Like it's, it's, it's a
very, when you have kids,
it's a very weird thing what happens
to you because you all the sudden it's,
you're not alone anymore. Like you like
you, you don't just have responsibility.
Like you have a dog you
have to feed or a plant,
you have a little person and you don't
want to fuck up that little person.
You're like shit and it feels overwhelming
and then the world feels so dangerous.
Change the view of the world.
Oh God, there's so much threat.
There's so much out there that
could signs, planes, stories too.
You read stories about terrible people
and terrible things that happen. Oh,
and then you're like, fuck,
I don't have to worry about,
this just happened to me afterward when
this happened to know somebody else to
then your little son or your little
daughter, you know? Yeah. That's wild bro.
That's crazy world.
And you,
you think of people differently because
you think of people as a project that
developed instead of being in a static
state. That's interesting. Did you,
did, did, do you think that something
like a emotionally happens to you?
Like at a level that the DNA
level? Yeah, the love you have.
Like Dave Chappelle said, this basket
was not only to do increase my love,
it increased my capacity for love. And
that's a great way of putting it. I would,
I would agree 100%. It increases
your capacity. You become a nurse.
At least me, I became a nicer person,
but I've seen it not work too.
I've seen people that just rejected.
I've seen men and women that
just don't want to be parents.
I've seen women move away from their kids.
They don't want to take
care of their kids.
I've seen men abandoned their families.
They just don't want to do it. It's crazy.
I don't know if it's a mental
health issue or if it's just,
some people just can't take it.
Like there's like attitudes,
and this is not just
about raising children.
It's about pretty much
anything difficult in life.
There's some people that
have a very low quit point,
very low. They just quit. Everything
that quit. It gets tough, quit, quit.
There's a lot of people that just quit.
And, uh, when you have a little like,
say if you have a little Theo in front
of you and you think about your life and
your childhood and like how
important it is for you to,
to raise this little person and give
him love and teach them about life and
protect him and keep him safe and
give them good lessons in life.
It just changes. Everything,
changes, everything, changes,
everything. But it also has very
overwhelming, it's overwhelming.
People get serious anxiety
when they have kids.
They start thinking about the
responsibility and the weight of it all.
Or they don't,
some people just fucking take pills and
lay on the couch and let their kids suck.
Fucking carpet glass and the fucking
stick forks into the wall sockets and play
with knives. People just don't,
some people don't give a fuck,
but some people are dumb. That's a,
that's a thing too, man. I, you know,
people don't want to say this,
but there's folks out there that
just aren't equipped for life.
I really believe that. I think Dee come
the dumb brother. That's what I'm saying.
Take the semen out of him.
And I'm saying like at a certain point,
but here's the problem.
You're dumb compared to physicists.
So who's the WHO's to judge and who's to
say that this person is really stupid,
couldn't have a brilliant child
that happens to men. A lot of times,
brilliant people come out of stay, need
adversity, man who knows what they need,
but it's like it's not our job to decide
who's stupid and who's not because it
gets slippery. Yeah. You,
you could get boxed into that
stupid corner in a different metric.
If you're hanging around with a bunch
of people from Stanford in and they're
looking steel,
Vons and neighborhood and they know
there's 10 people in the neighborhood,
but only nine can survive. It's lean
resources for 9:00 PM to get rid of me.
Probably. It depends on how
good you are digging ditches
or it could be better than him at that
thou has suddenly have a different scale.
I Dunno. It's a, have you
thought about having kids? Yeah,
I think about it a lot more like as I
get a little bit older and I just, yeah.
The thing for me is just like
about being brave, I think,
and just being willing to have my life
just be totally different and be okay
with that.
Yeah.
And just be in like willing to know that
I will be okay in that space, you know?
Um, I think it's hard.
Uh, it's like, I just,
it's like I'm just starting to
manage this space that I'm in,
like as just has a regular person and
then to get to that point where now it's
like, fuck, you have another ball. You
have two balls in the air, you know,
a wife and a kid, or, yeah.